[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID ARONCHICK: "Cloud
OnAir," live webinars
from Google Cloud.
We are hosting
webinars every Tuesday.
My name is David Aronchick.
And today, I will be
talking about Kubeflow.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform,
and we have Googlers
standing by to answer them.
Let's get started.
So as I mentioned I will be
talking about Kubeflow today.
Kubeflow is a brand new machine
learning platform designed
to make using machine learning
very, very easy on Kubernetes.
And the reason we
really approached
this problem is because we
heard over and over again
that customers are
looking to take advantage
of the great Kubernetes
platform and all
it provides, relative to
cloud-native applications,
and bring those same
kind of innovations
to machine learning.
Before I begin getting
into Kubeflow specifically,
a lot of people ask what's so
great about machine learning?
You hear about it all the time.
It's in the news.
You hear about all the great
new things that are coming out,
and people want to understand,
does machine learning
affect me?
Can I use machine learning
to change my business?
And the reality is you
really, really can.
What you see here is a
graph of Google data centers
and the amount of
energy that they
use per the amount of
compute that they create.
These are data
center engineers, who
spend their entire life getting
fantastic at tuning data
centers, making sure they run
properly, making sure they
are as efficient as possible.
They use all the
latest technologies.
They use 100% renewable
energy, and they really, really
spend all their
time focusing on how
to make our compute to provide
queries and Google Cloud
as efficient as possible.
When the team came
together, they
said what could we do next,
they looked at machine learning.
And as you can see here, simply
by applying machine learning,
they were able to save 40% over
already the best-tuned data
centers in the world.
And that's exactly what
machine learning does.
When they first saw these
results, they shook their head.
They couldn't believe
what was going on.
But this is the largest
expense they had,
and they were able to do
that through standard machine
learning techniques.
However, machine
learning is very hard.
People understand the standards
of programming and computing
and how to rollout
systems, and they've
been building those experiences
over the past 40 years.
But unfortunately,
the reality is
that there's a big separation
between all that ML goodness
that you heard on one side
and where people are today.
They don't know
whether or not it
applies to what their current
business problems are.
They don't know how to make
those applications work.
And they don't know,
even once you roll out
those applications,
if they can really
diagnose what's going on under
the hood, because a lot of ML
can be really inscrutable.
Why is it so complicated?
It's basically because it comes
down to these two situations.
Today, there really aren't any
great prepackaged ML solutions,
and there's a whole bunch
of reasons for this.
But basically, it comes down
to one of the two following
things--
either one, you have to
set up your entire system
from scratch.
That means integrating
with legacy systems.
That means customizing,
picking, and choosing
different solutions.
And eventually, once
you spend all that time
getting your system in exactly
the right size and shape,
you then have to migrate it
because your business needs
change.
Maybe you need to move
to new geo or locality,
maybe you have data in
different locations,
and you want to run
your machine learning
in different locations.
All those problems
now surface, and you
have to re-setup
all your systems
and re-integrate with brand
new set of legacy systems.
Or the alternative is you use
an entirely hosted solution.
And in the first five
minutes, that's great.
You get a first
look at exactly what
machine learning can provide.
Unfortunately, the
next five years
are nothing but pain
because you have everything
that you had on the left.
You have the same
issues setting it up.
You have the same issues
integrating with your legacy
systems.
And when it comes
to migrating, you're
now out of options
because you're locked
into a single deployment.
And certainly, not all
hosted solutions fall
into this category but
certainly, many of them
do because, in the
purpose of creating
those hosted solutions,
they've abstracted away
a lot of the customizability
and configurability
necessary for really
productionizing your ML
worklist.
So the question is, haven't
we heard this story before?
And the reality is we have.
Before I came to
work on Kubeflow,
I worked on Kubernetes.
And in 2015, when we first
got Kubernetes up and running,
we heard this over and
over and over again,
relative to containers
and Kubernetes.
People were building their
own bespoke orchestrators
their own bespoke ways of
rolling out containers,
especially in
production-ready ways,
and integrating them with
their legacy solutions
and figuring out how
to get across clouds.
When Kubernetes came
along, it really
enabled us to build
cloud-native applications.
And when we say
cloud-native applications,
we say not just giving you
all the components in the box
in order to do service
discovery and manageability
and declarative
application rollout
but really, extensibility.
About six months ago,
at KubeCon Austin,
we had a talk specifically
about the extensibility
of Kubernetes.
What this meant is you
get very clean layers
in between all the ways that
you roll out your application,
meaning that if you want to
extend in a specific way,
you're able to use the native
APIs without forking the code,
without having some bespoke
hardwired, welded together
solution.
You're able to use
those components
and extend it in the
way that make the most
sense for your business.
And what this
ultimately resulted in
was cloud-native apps.
These are applications designed
to run in a distributed way.
They're loosely
coupled together,
meaning you can swap in and out,
yet they're extremely scalable.
They're designed to handle
the realities of a modern data
center and modern application.
The single node goes down.
It knows how to recover.
If you need to migrate from A
to B, it knows how to do that.
If you need to use
core components,
like service discovery
or mounting storage,
you can handle that as well.
And it allows you and
your software engineers
to focus on just the components
that are the most important
for you, the things
that actually make
a difference for your business.
So what we would propose is that
we need the same capabilities
relative to cloud-native
ML, the same loose coupling,
the same scalability,
the same portability.
And for us, like I said, it does
come down to those components.
We want it to be
highly composable.
highly portable,
and we want it to
be highly scalable.
By composability, we mean
everyone focuses, when it comes
to ML, on building a model.
You might hear this
over and over again.
A brand new paper came out
about detecting diabetes just
through retinal scans, improving
the way that energy deployment
is used and all the
advances you get there,
discovering a new protein
through exploring space.
Those are fantastic
models, but the reality
is that when you go and
talk to any data scientist,
they see that the problem
is much, much larger.
It goes beyond just
building a model
to the actual end-to-end
stack of building
an overall deployment.
That includes data ingestion,
transforming the data,
exploring it, splitting it,
finally building your model,
and then validating that
the model is accurate.
And then rolling it out
to production-- something
that very frequently
is overlooked.
How do you roll it
out and track it?
How do you make sure it
doesn't drift over time?
How do you make sure it's better
than what you have out there
today?
That is what we were
talking about when
we say composability.
We need to provide all those
components to really allow you
for a production-ready
environment,
and especially because
every enterprise is
going to be slightly different.
One team might use Spark.
Another might use Hadoop.
Another might use their
own custom data processing.
You might use TensorFlow.
You might use PyTorch,
Caffe, MXNet--
doesn't matter-- or rolling
out the production--
whether or not you're
using Kubernetes
or you're on potentially
a hosted model serving.
All those components
are complicated,
and we want to give
you the ability
to natively choose
the things that
make the most sense for you.
Secondly, it comes
to portability.
When we think about
portability, this
is the reality of the world.
That entire stack, that
I described earlier,
that is just a component
of all the configuration
that you might have.
You run times, drivers,
OSes, accelerators all
under the hood, let alone
all those compositions
that you have above.
However, once you spend all that
time getting your experiment up
and running and so
on, then you have
to roll it out into a variety
of different environments, which
might be very, very different.
You could have something
for experimentation,
something completely different
for on-prem or cloud-based
training, and then finally,
potentially rolling out
to the cloud
public-private on-prem
for actually serving
it and integrating
with your application.
So that becomes more
and more challenging
because all that configuration
you did in one environment
now requires a
second set of effort
to go and replicate it for
these new environments.
And then finally, we
think about scalability.
A lot of people, when they
think about scalability,
it might just be more
nodes, but it's actually
far more complicated than that.
You could think
about whether or not
you're using CPUs, GPUs,
Google's brand new TensorFlow
processing units,
more CPUs per node--
are you using those properly--
disk networking concerns?
And then there's things
that are not just hardware.
How do you scale
up for skill sets?
Potentially, an intern to a data
scientist, a software engineer,
researcher, any of
those various things--
those are scalability
components as well.
You talk about teams.
Are the teams geolocated?
Does the team grow,
shrink over time?
And then finally,
number of experiments--
the most sophisticated
machine learning shops
are in fact running
thousands of experiments
simultaneously, testing
them off each other
and seeing what's
working and then tracking
those experiments over time.
All those fit into the
components of scale.
So those are the
three key components
that we want to bring
to cloud-native ML.
And as I said, the
things that are
great at that we already know.
It's containers in Kubernetes.
Except if you want to use
machine learning on Kubernetes,
unfortunately, you have to
get really, really smart
at a whole bunch of things--
containers, packaging,
service endpoints,
scaling, on and on and on.
These are all new concepts,
even for the most sophisticated
application teams, and
now layering Kubernetes
on top of that is a
lot for ML scientists
and data scientists to grasp.
So that is why we
introduced Kubeflow.
The idea behind it is to
make it easy for everyone
to develop, deploy, and manage
portable, distributed machine
learning on Kubernetes.
And for us, it looks
like the following.
The first is you think
about Kubernetes.
It provides a
wonderful abstraction
layer and a set of core services
and native APIs available.
And then you describe your
deployment for Kubeflow
using code, and you're
able to roll out
the exact same deployment
in all these places.
So that complicated
pipeline that
has been customized
exactly as you like
is now swappable for any
of these environments,
based on your needs.
And specifically, you
know two weeks ago,
at KubeCon in Europe, we
were pleased to announce
Kubeflow 0.1, our first official
release of our new platform.
Specifically, in
the box today, we
have a Jupyter notebook and
specifically JupyterHub.
We offer the tools for
multiarchitecture distributed
training, meaning you're
now able to use many nodes
and many accelerators on those
nodes in a very straightforward
way.
We also offer
multiframework serving
so you're able to use server
things like extra boost
and TensorFlow and so on using
standard components in the box.
We have a number of different
examples and workflows,
and best of all,
that last point,
we use ksonnet packaging to
allow you to customize it
for yourself.
So with that, I'd
like to show you
a brief demo of what
Kubeflow looks like to solve
a real-world business problem.
One of the most common
things that people use today
is around sentiment analysis.
So this might be where you
have a large body of text
that you want to
scan over and process
for understanding how
your business is reacting
to these various things.
I recorded this video
a little bit earlier.
Unfortunately, training
takes a little bit of time.
And we have a short
time, but I'll walk you
through exactly what we do.
So here you see this
is the Yelp data set.
It's published on Kaggle.
And it has many, many comments
about various restaurants
and things that people
might want to use.
And you can see here if we
looked at this middle thing,
it's a lot of text, and
standard text analysis might not
get at what you're looking for.
In this case, a little on the
pricey end but the baked goods
were good.
And that's particularly
hard because you
use the same word meaning
two different things
in a single sentence.
And so for that middle word,
we would probably say, wow,
that's actually a good review.
We should probably
see what happens.
So if I walk forward
and I look at how
it's wired into our
application, we'll go,
and we'll click
on the sentiment.
And unfortunately, it
looks like we're way off,
and this is not at all uncommon.
You'll have something
where you have a coarse way
of approaching the problem.
And even though a human can
figure out what's going on,
it might be very complicated.
If we go and look at the
code, this is not so good.
We're using standard
techniques to look through
for synonyms of things that are
good and things that are bad.
Let's see if we can do better.
Right now, what
I'm going to use is
something called Tensor2Tensor.
This is a standard machine
learning framework,
open sourced by Google.
It is designed to solve a
lot of these problems, where
you can basically take
large bodies of text,
paint them with
sentiment analysis,
say what's good and bad,
and roll them out to solve
some of these problems.
In this case, we've
already packaged it,
and you can see here that it
supports sentiment analysis.
And what we'll do
is we'll roll it out
to Kubeflow specifically.
So one of the most common
situations that we have today
is a data scientist might
not even have a Kubernetes
cluster available to them.
What they want to
do is they want
to start on their local
laptop and figure out
how to explore a particular
model to see whether or not
it will solve their problem.
So right here, I am
executing the command.
This simply says
to my laptop I want
to focus on using Minikube.
Minikube is a free to
use local Kubernetes
deployment that lets you test
out a number of solutions,
before you roll them
out to production.
So with that, I'm
going to take this,
and I'm going to
apply Kubeflow core.
This is something where we
have the hosted registry,
and this is the core components
that exist as part of Kubeflow
and with that, that's it.
That's the single
command that I need
to execute in order to spin
up a Kubeflow deployment.
You can see here,
after that, it gives me
a JupyterHub, which is
the standard interface
for doing a number of
machine learning exploration.
I go, and I'm able to
select from a number
of different prebuilt solutions.
In this case, we have all these
various different versions
of TensorFlow, GPU,
CPU support, and I'm
able to straight
through this configure
it using various CPUs, memory,
and extra resource limits,
including things
like accelerators.
Again, we're trying to
make this very, very easy
to begin using TensorFlow.
And with that, I now am going
to take that deployment--
and like I said, I'm
not going to show you
the training because,
unfortunately, it
does take a little bit.
But locally, what I've done is
I've downloaded Tensor2Tensor,
and I've started running it.
And what you can see here
is that though I deployed
Kubeflow, which is very
straightforward, what
I want to do is I
want to configure it,
based on my local environment.
And in this case, I've been
able to say using parameters--
without changing
any of the code--
I can say, well, look, this
machine doesn't have a GPU,
and I only need one worker.
That's the way of running
these actual applications
and so on and so forth.
So using parameters,
not changing code
or changing different
packages, I'm
able to set various things here.
And then I'll take
this, and I apply it.
And now I begin the
job of training.
It's looking at
my local data set.
It's looking at those nodes.
And you can see now with
just three commands,
I've gone from nothing
to a Kubeflow deployment
to now actually running a model
in a very straightforward way.
And you can see here that the
model is running appropriately.
So with that, because
it's a laptop,
that's not going to
train very quickly,
but I can see that
there's no syntax errors.
Everything is working properly.
So I think it's appropriate that
we actually take this and now
reapply it to the cloud.
Before I began this demo, I
created a Kubernetes cluster
using Google Kubernetes engine.
This is the overall
hosted service
that we use to host
Kubernetes compliant
clusters on Google Cloud.
And in this case, I'm going
to use a native feature
inside of Kubernetes
engine called Node Pools.
Node Pools allow you to create
multiple sets of nodes that
exist within a single
Kubernetes cluster,
and it lets me schedule
my jobs to the nodes that
are appropriate.
In this case, I'm going to
create one node pool that
has four nodes, each of which
have eight NVIDIA Tesla P100s.
And then I'm also going
to create a second node
pool that we are going to use
for scheduling our TPU jobs.
You can see there the eight
Tesla P100s associated
with those nodes,
and then we're also
going to create these TPUs.
TPUs are Google's
Tensor Processing Units.
Those are designed to run
TensorFlow particularly
quickly.
And you can see them that
they are scaled up right now.
So with that, we're going
to go, and we're going
to switch our configuration.
So now, again, without
making any changes,
I switched from looking
at my local cluster
to looking at the
one in the cloud.
And now I'm going to apply
that exact same deployment
to the cloud, and it's going
to spin it up and run it.
From there, we are going to
roll out our job to, again,
we're going to use
distributed TensorFlow.
But before I do that, I'm going
to swap out those parameters.
As I mentioned
earlier, before we said
we're not going to use any GPUs.
Now we're going to
have one GPU per node.
We're going to have two workers.
And we're going
to roll this out,
and it's going to use a
different data directory,
instead of using local.
And there you go.
So now, again, you saw literally
everything we had to do.
We change some parameters,
and we changed our context.
And we were able to roll
out the exact same thing
that we had locally to
this cluster in the cloud
to have it run
much more quickly.
We made one more swap.
We had a prebuilt
cluster for TPUs,
and you do have to
build differently
based on GPUs or CPUs.
And we'll roll that out as well.
And so, again, we just
added one more command,
and now we're going to run
simultaneous experiments
against both the TPUs and GPUs.
As you can see here, we're
walking through the Google
Kubernetes Engine.
You can see the
logs running there,
and you have the native support
for showing all the jobs that
are running in your Google
Kubernetes Engine cluster.
Now to see how
things are running,
we're going to swap to
look at TensorBoard.
TensorBoard also comes as part
of the core set of components
in Kubeflow.
And you can see here
that on our GPU cluster,
we're doing about two to three
experiments per second, which
is perfectly fine
for a large data set,
and then we're going to swap.
And after looking at the
GP1, let's look at the TP1.
And on the TP1, we're actually
able to get it much faster.
We're actually doing
about 16 times a second.
So we're able to
run that experiment
and see that in this particular
case, we get about a five times
acceleration of moving
from GPUs to TPUs.
Now that's not always the case.
GPUs may work better
for certain cases.
TPUs might work better
for other cases.
But the power of Kubeflow
is I was able to experiment
with those various
deployments, without making
any significant code changes--
just changing some parameters
and recompiling and I
was able to get that.
So now we're going to
do one final thing.
Remember our goal here was to
provide sentiment analysis.
You can see there we deployed
a brand new server to take
advantage of that model
that we have now trained,
and we're going to go
back to the Yelp text
and see how we did.
You can see-- remember, happy,
sad-- happy was not accurate.
Let's see what happens
when we swap it out,
and we have the predict,
and it works fine.
And so now, again, in a
very straightforward way,
using very standard models
that are published out there,
we were able to train on our
data set this Yelp reviews
and see a result that improved
our overall application.
So as you saw, very clean,
very straightforward way
to deploy machine learning to a
variety of different locations,
based on your business
needs and based
on the hardware and software
that you have available to you.
What you didn't see
was anything bespoke.
I was using native,
open source technologies
to solve these problems, using
standard machine learning
models I was able to deploy.
And what that means is greatly
reduces the amount of time
your software engineers,
your data pros, your data
scientists, your IT pros have to
spend customizing and building
their solutions together.
You also didn't see any
cloud-specific, non-portable
technology.
The exact same deployment I
had locally ran on the cloud,
and all I had to do was
change the parameters.
And finally, you didn't see any
forking of the Kubernetes APIs.
This isn't something where
you need to go to your IT pro
and say they have to take all
the software that they spent
rolling out, make it very easy
to deploy their applications
using Kubernetes, and
change it under the hood
to now support your brand new
machine learning workloads.
This uses native
Kubernetes APIs.
And really, we are at the start
of a brand new world here.
We want to use
data to save lives.
There's this wonderful
story out of Sweden
where a bunch of data scientists
looked at their hospital
records, and they
discovered that women
and stay-at-home
parents were being
injured at a disproportionate
rate after new snowfalls.
By looking at what
happened, they
realized that by doing nothing
more than changing the plowing
schedule for those
particular situations,
after new snowfalls, they
were able to plow sidewalks
before roads.
And what that
meant was that they
were able to save lives
and reduce injuries.
And that's a wonderful
story because that's really
what we're trying to unlock with
machine learning and Kubeflow.
We want to give people who are
not experts in data science
the intelligence to
make the difference
for their overall solutions.
And for us, that means
we want to give nurses
and civil engineers
and professors
all the information necessary
for them to understand
what is affecting their
world and how to make better
decisions using this data.
So finally, we are
just getting started.
You can see here there are
a number of different folks
who have contributed to
the Kubeflow platform.
We announced
Kubeflow in December
at KubeCon in North America.
And over the past six
months, we have been stunned
with how quickly it has grown.
Over 700 commits, 71
different contributors,
17 different companies-- you
can see some of them here--
who are already
contributing the platform.
And we really do want to make
this an open platform that
is designed to run everywhere.
As you saw, we went from laptop
to Google Container Engine.
We support anywhere you are
running a Kubernetes compliant
architecture.
On-prem, in the
cloud, on your laptop,
we support Kubernetes
compliance.
For what's next, we plan on
getting to our 0.2 release.
That's going to
happen this summer,
and we have some focus around
getting to much easier setup.
Right now, unfortunately,
does require a little bit
of understanding of ksonnet
and native Kubeflow components.
We want to make that very, very
easy for you to start with.
Second, we really want to
focus on taking advantage
of all the work that the
Kubernetes community is
currently doing.
We want to abstract
away a number
of the different
components, including
auto-scaling,
improved accelerators.
We want to make it so that
your data scientists can simply
describe declaratively what they
would like to have this job run
as, and Kubernetes takes care
of all the stuff under the hood.
We also want to support more
packages and frameworks.
While you saw a demonstration
with TensorFlow,
we have a number of folks in
the community who are already
contributing, PyTorch, Caffe.
We've heard requests for
[INAUDIBLE] and MXNet
and so on and so forth, and
we want to support that as
much as possible.
And in particular, if there
are particular scenarios
that you're hearing from or
you'd like us to extend to,
we'd love to hear that next.
And then finally, the
best feature that we like
is the one that we
haven't heard yet.
It is a completely
open platform.
We have an open community.
Everything is done in the public
via our open source repository,
and it really is an open design.
One of the things that we
learn best about Kubernetes
was really listening
to all the ways
that people wanted to use the
platform that it didn't yet
support.
That helped us
understand the ways
that we should extend, the
places we should invest in,
and how to do new open ideas
and open source development.
And we really are open.
We have an open source repo.
You can come in any time.
You can contribute.
We have Slack channels.
We have email lists.
We have GitHub
with issues, and we
want to hear more than
anything what to do next.
And while it is a 0.1 release
and maybe a little bit
early for your environment,
all the components
that are running inside
it are battle tested.
There are TensorFlow and
JupyterHub and Ambassador
and [? Selden ?] and
TensorFlow serving.
These are things that
have been out in the wild
for a long, long
time, and they are
more than ready to experiment
with and give us feedback.
And so with that,
I'm going to wrap up.
Please stay tuned
for the live Q&A.
Thank you very much,
and welcome back.
So we have a lot of questions.
We'll try get through them all.
The first one, do you
support other frameworks
besides TensorFlow?
Yes, absolutely.
We started with
TensorFlow because,
at Google, that's what
we're familiar with,
and that's what the teams
already had ready to go.
We absolutely want to
support other frameworks.
We want to support
every framework.
We want to have them as native
packages that we test nightly
and roll them out.
And so more than
anything, we are really
looking for the community
to help us prioritize.
Give us your feedback and
we will help bubble things
to the top.
As I mentioned, we do have
several operators already
checked into the codebase
that you can start
experimenting with right now.
But it is absolutely
a core of Kubeflow
to support all the machine
learning frameworks
that people would want.
Can I run Kubeflow
outside of Google Cloud?
Absolutely.
As you saw, we support all
the way from your laptop
to any Kubernetes compliant
cloud or a deployment.
So whether or not that you're
on-prem, hybrid, Google Cloud,
another cloud, as long as
it's Kubernetes compliant,
it should run great.
If not, we want to hear
about it because that
is part of our core mission.
How do I customize Kubeflow?
So as you saw there are
some standard packages.
Kubeflow core and
others that run inside
in our overall registry.
We actually support a number of
different ways to configure it.
Kubeflow uses
ksonnet from Heptio
to create packages that are
highly customizable that use
parameters and other things.
And you can either
download and tweak
those using parameters or
the native extension points,
or you can write your own.
And you don't have to submit
those to a central registry.
You can have your own private
registry that Kubeflow can use
or any of your team can use
that's appropriate for you.
What's the roadmap for Kubeflow?
We expect, as I mentioned,
to hit 0.2 to this summer.
And shortly thereafter,
we expect to go straight
to 1.0 in our GA release.
More than anything,
we want to accelerate
peoples' solutions with ML.
And so for us, as
soon as we feel
like we can have that production
ready environment that actually
solves solutions today, we're
very excited to hit 1.0.
More than anything, we are
ready to listen to you.
And so if there are
key features missing
we would love to
hear about them.
If it feels like all
the features are there
and it's just a matter of
finishing off and getting
everything production ready,
we can focus on that too.
So more than anything,
we'd love to hear from you.
Do you support ML
accelerators in Kubeflow?
Absolutely, the machine learning
framework for Kubernetes
has done a bunch of work,
relative to ML and ML
accelerators.
This has been with contributions
from Google, from NVIDIA,
from Intel--
a number of different
folks making sure
that the way to
extend at Kubernetes
is very straightforward.
So you can pick and
choose the accelerators
that are native to you, without
having to do customization,
without having
necessarily to run
a different version of
your container runtime
in order to support
ML or accelerators.
Kubeflow, our goal is to
not do any of that stuff.
We want to leverage all the
work that the Kubernetes team is
doing under the
hood and simply make
it available via annotations
or higher level constructs
that you can describe
your ML workloads
and say I'd like
to roll this out.
And I'd like to use this
type of accelerator here,
or I'd like to use that
type of accelerator there.
And Kubernetes will take care of
the hard stuff under the hood.
Are there any detailed tutorials
on which you can deep dive?
Absolutely, we have workshops,
tutorials on GitHub.
I highly recommend a number
of walkthroughs and videos
that people have done.
I'd also suggest going to
our examples directory.
We already have a number
of different really cool
examples--
one we did in partnership
with the team from GitHub
around doing GitHub issue
summarization to make
it very easy to
understand what's
happening in larger
GitHub repos.
That's all built
on top of Kubeflow.
And as you saw
there, it is our goal
to make available a
number of different models
just like you saw with
Tensor2Tensor to make
it very straightforward to
download standard models
and run them.
Part of what we're trying
to do with Kubeflow
really is solve the
reproducibility crisis.
In machine learning, it
is a very common scenario
where you might have a
machine learning scientist
at one organization who
publishes their research,
and it basically is impossible
for any other data scientist
to reproduce that experiment.
Our goal, our long-term
vision with Kubeflow
is really solve that
and have everyone
be able to publish your
Kubeflow code, your model,
and your data, and make
that an entire package that
allows anyone to reproduce
a given machine learning
solution.
And so you'll see that over
and over and over again.
We are out there working
with researchers and machine
learning data
scientists to figure out
how to make that happen.
Finally, when would I use
Kubeflow over Cloud Machine
Learning Engine?
Cloud Machine Learning Engine
is an offering from Google
that offers hosted
prediction and inference,
and the fact is that's
exactly what Kubeflow
is designed to do.
Machine Learning Engine
is a hosted solution.
So if you don't want to think
about scaling up or using GPUs
or not using GPUs, worry
about serving or anything
like that, it offers a
fantastic endpoint for you
to upload your model and
Cloud Machine Learning Engine
takes care of the rest.
Kubeflow is highly composable.
We offer an orchestration
engine built in called Argo,
from the Argo Project,
which is also open source.
And from that, it offers a
number of different steps
to walk through
all the components
that you saw on some of
those earlier slides.
In any one of those steps,
you could say, actually,
I don't want to use
the component that
was built into Kubeflow.
I'd really prefer to use this
hosted software as a service,
just handle this
particular step,
whether or not that's
training or inference
or anything along the lines.
You can instruct
Kubeflow to say, OK,
you've reached this
step, now call out
to this external service.
Once you're done, call
back to this webhook
and I'm ready to go.
And that really is it.
The idea is that
Kubeflow provides
this more general
orchestration, framework,
and stack that you
can swap in and out.
If you want to customize or
self-host or do something
for yourself, then use Kubeflow.
If you'd like there to be
a managed solution that
took care of everything
for you, then you
might use something like
Machine Learning Engine
for that particular step.
And I should reiterate that that
is a key component of Kubeflow.
We want to make it very,
very easy for you to deploy
and plug-in to your existing
legacy applications.
And so whether or
not you already
have a data processing solution,
which is extremely common.
Arguably, anyone who's doing
a certain amount of data
processing today
or are collecting
a certain amount
of data today has
some data processing pipelines.
That's fantastic.
As long as you're
able to surface
the processing of that data
to Kubeflow, that's great.
You don't have to run
that particular component
inside Kubeflow.
You can simply connect
the component to Kubeflow
to that data
processing pipeline,
and it should run fine.
And so with that,
we're wrapped up
with all our Kubeflow questions.
We'll be online and available
to answer any further questions.
Or as you saw with
all of the community
framework and connection
points, you're
more than welcome
to come and jump
in and ask us
questions directly,
and we try to be
very, very responsive.
With that, stay tuned
for the next session--
Cloud Armor, Protecting
Your Application From
DDOS Attacks With Google.
And thank you very
much for the time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]